notre métier n'est pas de faire plaisir
non plus de faire du tort il est de dire
la vérité et il est de porter la plume
dans la plaie ces mots qui sonnent comme
un mantra pour les journalistes sont
ceux d'albert londres albert londres un
nom qui vous dit certainement quelque
chose mais oui vous en avez forcément
entendu parler journaliste légendaire il
a donné son nom au prix albert londres
créé en 1933 un an après sa mort un jury
assemblées autour de sa fille décerne à
un grand reporter le prix albert-londres
goncourt du journalisme le bon cours du
journalisme c'est le prix du reportage
le plus prestigieux de france pas
étonnant albert londres cours et d'un
front de l'actualité à un autre
correspondant de guerre dès la première
heure gagnant le front en voiture à
bicyclette à pied il bouleverse les
lecteurs du matin par de saisissants
récit des bombardements de rentes et
d'arras
c'était une plume un style et une
certaine idée du journalisme il s'est
attaqué sans aucun sectarisme mais avec
sa seule bonne foi à l'injustice le
racisme le traite des blanches les
conditions de détention au bagne albert
londres ce fut aussi un style nouveau
d'écriture vivant chaleureux accessible
à tous et aujourd'hui encore ses écrits
n'ont pas pris une ride des écrits qui
n'ont pas pris une ride et à entendre
pierre assouline biographe d'albert
londres les journalistes auraient tout
intérêt à son inspiré le ballon faisait
du reportage sur le terrain il y avait
la couleur de l'émotion des bruits des
odeurs alors que de plus en plus et
joris qui font du reportage aujourd'hui
ont tendance à aller très loin pour
éditorialisé ce qui est une erreur ils
font de l'analyse au lieu de faire et du
commentaire au lieu de montrer de faire
parler des gens croient qu'il a toujours
eu une vision peut-être un peu trop
poétique du monde mais en tout cas
beaucoup plus original est beaucoup plus
authentique plus vécu que bon nombre de
journalistes aujourd'hui et le terran
c'est là où il a terminé sa vie albert
londres est mort dans l'incendié du
paquebot qui le ramenait de chine en
1932 il couvrait alors la guerre
sino-japonaise
[Musique]